foreign
and I think it's a set of skills but if
you grew up in a house where your job
was the emotional regulation of the
adults if it was your job to make sure
Dad didn't get mad or mom was always
saying hey y'all need to do this because
Dad's coming home and he's gonna you
know how he gets when or Dad's like oh
dude your mom's about to get set off if
you all don't get this the kids learn oh
it's our job to make sure Mom and Dad
are okay right which is a weight they
can't no kid can carry no that
transitions to adulthood either you're a
spouse who takes [__] on as your
responsibility to make sure your husband
or wife is happy at all times yeah or
there's such an inner age that you
circle the wagons around your own life
and you're gonna get the life that you
want whether you got to borrow up to the
hill you're gonna drive that car you can
live in that neighborhood in that house
you're gonna marry this person you can
do whatever you want
ultimately the grenades that are thrown
back and forth are well you made me fill
in the blank or you said this thing so I
couldn't just sit there and you did it
like everything is I have to or I'm
irresponsive
the greatest Flex I've ever heard in my
life ever ever was somebody was having a
conversation with Jocko and they said so
you're walking with your family down the
street right former Navy SEAL jacked
human beings just being in his presence
is like
yeah yeah I I need to go and on top of
it he's in world class world world class
Jiu Jitsu player
so
a guy says so somebody comes down the
sidewalk and just confronts you and your
family and it's like what's up man we
got a problem he goes what do you do
and jogger said well I reach over and
grab my wife's hand and my daughter's
hand and we would just go to the other
side of the street and go that way and
head home
and the guy was flabbergasted it was
like what
but what about defending your wife's
honor and like your kids
and he said two really important things
number one he said
there are a handful of men on planet
Earth who can defeat me in hand-to-hand
combat and they do that for a living and
he goes
what honor do I get out of beating up
some guy on the sidewalk yeah and then
he said something that was super
powerful he said if I
have to wait until that moment to show
my wife that I honor her I have failed
her in every way the smartest thing is
to get my family home safely I don't
know if this guy's got a friend with
guns or with bottles or with like I
don't know right you're just gonna go
home yeah and I remember thinking that
ability to step out of Chaos in that
moment right that's an egregious example
on the street with a Navy SEAL 99 of us
are at home yeah and our wife says that
thing or a husband does that thing again
right every time our kids come in and
say this thing
and every defense mechanism we have
gears up and here we go right you've had
to cultivate over years
an attorney's job is just to get and I
you're at a place now I guarantee you
they're like I'll get Jefferson I'll get
it yeah you know what I mean like yeah
I'll set them up oh it's a challenge now
it's a game yeah like uh like and you
know there's so much ego in the legal
profession I'll get Jefferson I'd set
him off what are some skills that people
can practice to begin to back up detach
as Jacob to disassociate to to take
myself from in the middle of the
hurricane to 30 000 feet where it's safe
yeah what I tell my clients when that
happens because I train them because
somebody's about to try and knock them
off kilter like you started with
I have to train them and how not to let
that happen yeah and you you're training
people who have been like oh yeah their
kids are not alive anymore oh yeah or
they they think they had a leg amputated
like you're dealing with people who have
are highly charged right extremely
highly charged people who who do have a
chip on their shoulder somebody who has
been a victim of something but it's it's
even more than that I mean I am hired to
handle other people's problems I get
hired to handle somebody else's beef
that's not even mine so somebody's other
side's mad at me I'm like hey I didn't
cause this there's a hundred bucks yeah
but I'll be glad to step in right and
then on the other side there's another
attorney who's been hired to make me
look bad like that's their sole purpose
it's to ruin my case yeah you know and
and that's and you have to coordinate
and balance
how I'm gonna have them communicate
because how they represent themselves
is everything and how they communicate
and so what I always tell them is
let your first word be your breath the
first word out of your mouth is your
breath and so when I instead of just
saying take a breath I say no
make your first word I turn it into I
mean the affirmative yes here's an
action yeah that's that's what first
thing you say is your breath
and because so often I mean and you know
this that our body's tight our shoulders
it gets up in our ears like we're just a
dog with you know the back of the hair
standing up ready to go but when you
take a breath
I just was you said it I did it and my
body went yeah right it's physiologic
right yeah oh yeah it's huge well yeah
you're telling your body there's no
threat oh gosh you know yeah and so too
often when I respond to somebody in a
way that is equaling their energy
somebody comes in and makes a comment at
me I have the choice in that moment do I
do I try and man up I try and oh you
want to have this measuring contest but
if if I'm able to take their power away
without doing any of that because I'm
I'm telling my body and I'm telling them
you're not a threat to me and like I
physically I'm telling my body they're
not a threat and with my words you know
just like saying maybe so or I'll say
you know well maybe you're right
oh hey they go uh what do I do with this
what do I what do I say now if I tell
them maybe you're right you know they go
all right
uh
they have no words they have no words I
mean too often then then they come back
and later apologize yeah because now
that now they're thinking you know well
why did I say then why'd I say that yeah
but but had I responded defensively they
got exactly what they want then then
I've Justified their next step then so
if I come back with something you know
with a another comment that gets
defensive that's offensive to them I've
given them rules of Zinger
I've just given them a stepladder that's
all I've done I mean they they they're
throwing it out hoping that I take a
bite you know and if you if you don't
bite it then
what you do just kind of reel it back up
and go home yeah nothing happened but
there there is I mean
not to generalize on multiple fronts
here but I'm going to yeah you're a
Texas male like I am right and there's a
and I'm using that like
broadly speaking there is a wired in
response it's like you can't talk to me
like that like yeah so for men and women
or I'm tired of taking this or I've been
taking this my whole life or yeah there
is a truth to
I'm going to respond in in the in the
moment like this because I'm playing a
different game and I'm playing I'm I'm
working towards an outcome right
but there's also that very human I'm
driving home and I can't believe that
dude said that yeah man that made me mad
yeah so going back to that previous uh
the previous law experiment yeah there's
a wife and her husband comes home and
she's lying and she sits down
and immediately her first words are her
breath
[Music]
just that was your day
not in a it's a check-in yeah not in a
sarcastic way but a genuine like how's
your day
there's still that
you told me you're gonna be on time yeah
and now you're gonna rattle off some
story yeah yeah yeah right hey how do
you on give a process on the way home I
can release I can have them release that
kind of frustration it's not the way you
say it's what it's what your words are
and for example so this woman she takes
a big breath
husband sitting in maybe he's standing
up by the sink he has he hasn't said
anything he knows he's not right kids
are in bed she's at the kitchen table
and she takes a breath and goes
so how was your day
he goes all right blah blah blah blah
blah blah
can we
talk about something
this is something important to me you
framed the conversation and so about her
not him you guys just genius yeah yeah
and then you say one she's she's not
starting with you did it again
it's gone he has to go to war now yeah
yeah he has no choice that's right but
when you say you frame the conversation
of I like to talk about something that's
important to me and I know that it's
important to you too
and my hope is that it when we get done
talking
you know we're gonna be able to you're
gonna be able to come back tomorrow and
we're gonna all have dinner the right
way
and you you just have that that
you say what do you do with that
frustration
it's not the emotions it's that you need
to get out it's the words because you
feel like they don't understand me
they're not acknowledging me they don't
understand how important this is and
you're not going to relay that message
with your emotion when you when you come
when you come at it strong like that
they're not hearing your words they're
hearing your tone well it's
physiological yeah everybody's
responding before they've even thought
of you you got it so and most of the
time we're I mean we're horrible
predictors of what our message sounds
like and looks like and the yeah yeah
you could say why are you yelling me I'm
not yelling at you
right right yeah but I'm going I'm
looking for ways that you're hurting me
yes and you can say hey you're late why
are you yelling right and now yeah and
oh yeah that and that's a very like
classic it's you're just uh diverting
the attention you're deflecting and all
of a sudden it's uh and I know if I
think maybe I've done something on this
before it's like well I'm sorry that I'm
such a horrible person
I'm sorry I'm just trying to be a good
husband I'm sorry that I have to work so
much and it's just straight manipulation
yeah is what that is
and the the way to
back up is how so if somebody were to
come in and say like some I'm just
trying to think I'm thinking of a
particular co-worker who would look at
me and go sorry I'm just so dumb and I
don't know everything
that's just it's just such a passive
weak move and I have the impulse to yeah
be like no you know what man but it's
backing out and me saying that's
that's
that's some God on his life not mine oh
and that's that's a perfect way to say
it so whenever they put out that kind of
apology it's not an apology it's it's um
it's a bunch of slathering of sun lotion
on their guilt and they're just trying
to cover it up because your son is
beaming right right so they're trying to
protect 50 SPF yeah because they know
that you could be coming in hot and
they're wanting to deflect you anything
else because once you say that sorry
that I'm such a Negative quality
self-deprecating whatever they're hoping
that you take the bait and go you're not
terrible oh you always think I'm
terrible I mean you always and then like
remember that one time and boom is gone
like that you've lost you've lost the
moment but instead if you're able to say
I don't need you to apologize
for how you're you're feeling but you
can't apologize for coming in late
you know the the ability to to shift
that because you're caught one you're
calling it out second of all you're
still maintaining control you gotta tell
you the third thing that it's a gift and
this is doesn't feel like a gift in the
moment but for
especially for people in professional
relationships or romantic relationships
you're actually giving me a road map
and we expect people especially when
we're mad to read our minds and to know
exactly what they did and why they did
it and how you can make me feel better
because it's your job right yeah by
saying
you don't apologize for how you feel
right I do need to apologize because you
were late I just gave you a laser path
right and you can choose to follow it or
not but I have to have enough control
over my emotions to know what the actual
issue is here and what I'm going for
here and is it to win is it to crush you
is it to catch you yeah or is it
to have dinner as a family around this
table that's my long-term goal here yeah
oh yeah you just give somebody a path
yeah but man you got that takes a lot of
humility to take that path but it's just
not easy I think it's a gift it well
yeah it is not is not easy and even for
somebody who practices it it's it's
still it's it's not it's not easy
because you you want that immediate you
know just guttural reaction to yell to
fight to get after it never ends well I
mean it just doesn't because what
happens let's here we go I like this so
you you you and I get an argument or I
mean we're after it we're saying
terrible things to each other I'm my
face looks mad I'm bowed up you're bowed
up or husband or wife you're saying
horrible things bring the stuff up in
the past
what happens there's a there's a break
where everybody says I'm out of here
different room whatever
what happens when you come back
your Tone's a little softer
you're slower with your words
you had
I didn't mean what I said there I I was
just I was frustrated with
when you know
our our son did X Y and Z and it just
makes me feel like a failure that I I
couldn't do I can't get him to and and
all of a sudden you realize that what
they were initially mad about was
nothing even close to what y'all were
yelling about
but I mean if you can just do that at
the beginning at the beginning that's
right yeah I always tell folks don't if
you can now as an attorney you're
getting paid to enter into an octagon
together right yeah in a marriage I
always tell like don't have that fight
right now when you're mad that's not the
time to dissect what just happened same
thing with an email or a text yeah just
don't time has a funny way of just
clarifying yeah and dissolving it yeah
like if I hold off on a text or an email
I said maybe I get an email that's
snarky from an opposing counsel oh I
have a response I'll type that out again
all right delete delete and then
within a day I got in I'll need to say
that
what I wish everybody like could really
chew on is that there's so much power in
that ability
to be able to know your own strength
inside of you that I nobody can make me
say anything that I don't want to say
and I have the ability to not react if I
if I so choose because what they said I
put in the trash Oh you wanted me to put
that on my plate that's funny no that's
the dog's eating them probably the
number one lesson I took away from
working with attorneys for all those
years was
that phrase there's power in the pause
and
the person who speaks last loses and it
was this like I don't have to say
anything right now I had never heard it
I love you you say it better like
oh was that for me because yeah is this
supposed to hurt yeah yeah like oh I'm
sorry like I was at your best uh my bad
right um but there's something so
powerful about
I'm not gonna say anything yeah oh yeah
I'm just gonna let it hang yeah it's
it's a and once you get the hang of it
it changes everything oh man it's it's
it is a game changer in your life it
really is and you know this when
somebody
put something out there
well I had to do this and this and this
and your first word I love how you say
that my first word is breath yeah
just takes about 60 seconds before they
start going
well I mean yeah and then they'll you
see that liar they'll reverse their
their they'll reverse the car all the
way down back the driveway oh yeah all
the way up that's exactly right like
people who who say something that some
would have a lie I want you to believe
something that's not true it's you just
imagine them coming in hot in the house
they Park up to the garage and then you
don't respond
and their weight and go away it is
he's not buying it
I'm gonna actually put this in Reverse
yeah yeah actually because they can't
take that silence yeah they can't take
that song I learned um doing student
conduct all those years it became
important for me to sit when I would
call a student in and say hey I just got
this report that you should actually
assaulted somebody are you or selling
drugs or whatever yeah
I knew that by walking in my office
every fight or flight mechanism that
human had was set and so I used to
always walk them through everything and
then I would always end it with you got
24 hours from this point
you had 24 hours to come back and say
Here's what actually happened here's my
role in it and I'm gonna count it as
though it happened here because my end
goal was I was trying to teach students
how to become functional adults yeah and
had a field fight or flight and still
tell the truth anyway how to feel like
ah yeah yeah and then hang in there in
the moment yeah and I think if you have
that same kind of Grace with your spouse
like the goal here is not to win
arguments the goal is to have a great
life to make a great marriage and to
race great kids and if we can always
keep that thing in motion then it might
be we're gonna Circle back tomorrow
right I feel often in spouse
relationships and and I see this on the
legal side
it's not that they just want to call it
out they want you to they want you to
know that you're bad they want you to
know that you're not a good husband so
it's like they it's like they want you
to download
I think you're bad and I need you to
know it you don't feel it yeah and they
and nothing good comes comes out of that
I mean I am
if you take the position of I'm never
gonna be the first to throw the first
stone because when the Microsoft
microscope you know turns on you
yeah it's you want that same you get
real quiet yeah that's right that's
right but there's something even about
if you if I'm sitting with a couple and
they've you know you got a Serial
cheater just infidelity infidelity
you're not making me leave
I'm choosing based on my values that I'm
not going to be with somebody who cheats
on me I am taking full ownership that
I'm ending this marriage that's right
right you didn't make me do anything
yeah and the more I can sit in that yeah
there's like I'm standing up just
explaining right right you just sit up
taller right yeah
um there's just strength and power and
oh you you can't make me do anything but
then you also have to choose I chose to
scream at that guy or I chose to try to
make her feel really bad yeah which is
just weakness and cowardice to be honest
with you I wish it was a different
language for it that's kind of weird no
no that's exactly what it is it's a it's
a reflection of your your lack of
confidence because most of the time when
we do have that that yelling reaction we
do say something that's snippy
if you're really honest with yourself
you regret it every time yeah and it's
not too long that you you regret and go
why did I say that and what you're going
to do you apologize and so often
especially manipulators kind of these
people that have very strong
narcissistic traits are masterful at
getting you to make these kind of
comments
so that then you are the one who is now
the offender you're the bad guy you're
the bad guy yeah I'm the one who came in
late through the door but you're the one
who can't appreciate this who always
nags about this and now all of a sudden
you find yourself the one apologizing
and also it depends like how you say it
well I need I I didn't like how you said
it you need to apologized for the way
you said your tone yeah your tone which
is also very true but the the people who
are masterful at it
it was somebody who's not equipped for
it they'll they'll they'll run that song
a million times a little bit long yeah